The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART:
We're going to deal
with three major
topics between now
and the end of the semester.
The first one is today's.
And that is what is the
relationship between the way
a city is made and its form.
Is there a relationship
between the way a city is made
and the form that it takes?
Next week, we will start
with an examination
of the relationship between
social structure and spatial
structure.
I'll do case studies for a
number of cities next week,
probably Jerusalem
and Johannesburg.
After that, we will look
at contemporary form models
selectively until the
end of the semester.
What would be nice would be
if you could use the material
that we've done, which I
suppose is a kind of a history,
as a reference to
some of the questions
that we're going to be
asking of current events.
Today I'm going to spend
a bit of time talking
about the process by which the
World Trade Center in New York
was replaced by
the Freedom Tower.
I don't know if any of
you know this story--
in broad terms,
perhaps not in detail.
In one of the pieces
of reading, you
will find a comment by
Margaret Crawford who
used to teach urban
design at Harvard when
the article questions
whether, after Robert Moses,
there's a process by
which New York is still
going to produce great things.
She says, "The
story of democracy
is one of constant improvement.
To look for perfect
answers is the wrong way
of looking at it."
So if she's correct,
the important thing
is that the result of a struggle
to produce a certain form
is contingent and,
most importantly,
to be oriented towards the
conditions of the struggle
and the education and
learning that takes place even
if the product isn't perfect.
That argument would mean that
the society is constantly
in a state of change
and is much more
likely to be associated with
the model of buildings which
can change at the same rate
as society wishes to change,
the Russians being very
intrigued by this relationship.
Am I being far-fetched?
Do you imagine that Melnikov's
project for the Pravda building
which has three rotating
cores has something
to do with the speed at
which decisions are made
and communicated to the public?
It's a bit far-fetched.
We don't perhaps engage
in the relationship
between social process
and form making
in as direct a
relationship as that.
But some people looking
at is Skidmore, Owings,
and Merrill's Freedom
Tower, which, by the way,
is 1,776 feet high, 1776
being an important date
in American history, tries to
connect the imperial quality
of a building by its height.
The Burj Khalifa
in Dubai is taller.
It's over 2,000.
And I don't think there's
any attempt in that society
to link its height to a
particular event in Islam.
But we play games.
I've listed nine ideas about
the relationship between form
and social process.
And I'm only going to spend
our time on a few of them.
I want to talk about the concept
of relying on a super figure
and using the case of
Robert Moses in New York.
Anybody read Robert Caro's book?
OK.
Well, so we use
ignorance as all of us.
In the case of
making decisions, I
will use the example of the
process by which the World
Trade Center was replaced in
some detail, the various five
stages of its procedure.
You are free to take
part in this discussion.
I'd like to hear your opinion
as to some of the assertions
I'm going to make.
Briefly, I'm going to deal also
with the concept of educating
citizens.
If you see form and
people as two items,
you can argue that
if you change people,
you change their
way of understanding
the form of places.
And the number of
projects that I
want to look at very
briefly with you,
which focus on changing
the nature of people,
rather than to--
you'll again look back
to last Tuesday's class.
One of the great concepts of
the young Soviet urbanists
after 1918 was that they
had a new clientele who
could be shaped to live
up to the qualities
of the Soviet society which
was newly being formed.
One of the problems
of the industrial city
was the fact that the client
structure was so fossilized.
There had been a number
of attemps to use urbanism
to try to educate
people and to change
this quotient,
this relationship.
I'm not going to
spend a lot of time
on redressing social imbalance.
I'll just mention it and give
an example of it from Boston
and spend less
time on confronting
the system as a way of changing
the society and its form.
Kevin Lynch argues that the real
issue in the contemporary city,
and he's really talking
about the American city,
is that they are a host of agent
families, industrial firms,
city agencies, developers,
investors, regulatory
and subsidizing agencies, and
so on and so on and so on, who
produce a process which
at best is fragmented,
plural and bargaining.
The public in this case has
a number of ways of acting,
typically.
First of all, they
are public works.
The public may build
infrastructure and buildings
at will.
It can do so in an
uncontested manner.
He doesn't have to
deal with the market.
In some societies, as in great--
well, not in Great Britain.
In some societies, or
certainly in Soviet Russia,
all land was belonged to the
state and private ownership
of land only became a slower--
I think it's now about
50% of total urban land.
The public can engage
with the private sector
in many kinds of relationships.
These relationships
have modified and been
exhausted almost in the range.
They range from the
classic Seagram Building
in New York, which traded
off, which the public ceded
floor area ratio
increases in return
for setting back the building
to provide public space.
There are many more current
trade-off off situations.
There are many in Boston.
The one that I'm thinking
of is the new hotel
on the waterfront--
I forget its name--
which has a terrace which runs
up against the public garden.
The trade-off is that the
city has allowed the hotel
to use the terrace for
the service of alcohol
and so on, in return of which
the private firm maintains
the garden.
There's a lot of
maintenance switches.
If you look after my house
while I'm going on holiday,
I will pick up your
mail when you come back.
This really operates more
extensively on a smaller scale
as do most urban design
decisions in current urbanism.
The third thing that
the public sector can do
is create the incentives.
The building of most of downtown
office building in Boston
was created by
121(d) legislation,
which gave tax breaks for
the building of new office
buildings.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: No, no, no.
There was no building of a
new office building in Boston
during the '50s and
'60s, and this comes
late John Hancock building.
The first John Hancock
building probably
dates from about 1960 or so.
They are older
buildings, but the spate
of new office development
was promoted largely
by this public sector
deciding that one of the ways
to incentivize private
market activity
was to use the tax system.
The public sector
has enormous power
in playing around
with the tax system,
because it's a negative
system of cost.
You lose what--
I don't want to go into
the economic detail.
It's complicated.
And there are a lot of theories
about whether it's good or bad.
But this is just
an example of where
it was used to build a
skyline for a city which
had no particular attraction
to office development.
At times, the city--
and I'm using
Boston, because there
are a lot of local examples,
rather than San Francisco,
which is used the trade-off of
public-private relationships
quite remarkably in
rebuilding the waterfront.
And there's a building on the
river which houses factories
for making pillows.
It's between-- I don't know
what the bridge is called,
and the other bridge.
It's where you come
off the freeway.
It's next to where Harvard's
Business School starts.
You know the building.
It looks like I don't know what.
I mean I can't describe it.
You could say that this
could be the argument.
The public sector says, we
cannot afford to lose jobs.
These properties are within
the municipality of Boston,
not of Cambridge.
It pays us to yield a site to
a corporation, a site which
it prefers because of the
publicity that it gets,
in order to stop it from
leaving Boston and going
to another city, where it may
equally prosper or prosper
even more.
So if the policy is
that the river is
a sacrosanct public entity
which provides enormous benefit
to the city, hidden and real,
it should not sacrifice its land
on the river for purposes which
are not closely associated
with human activity.
Not factories.
You don't put factories
on a modern river,
but you put factories
on a modern river
in order to keep those jobs.
This is the kind of complicated
way in which the city is made.
I think it's a very silly,
stupid decision of short term.
There's no body
authority which maintains
the rights of the river.
There are grassroot
organizations
which are friends
of the river and try
to protect the river from
pollution, and so on.
But the river is not
taken up by the city
and then used as a
sacrosanct commodity, even
economic commodity.
It's willing to trade off all
kinds of short-term benefits,
keeping Biotene--
I don't know if it's Biotene.
I don't know what the company
is, the drug company that--
anyway, let's move on.
The public has two other
propositions in its power.
It can regulate activity.
It can write bylaws.
Those are both for protection
and for the possibility
of incremental change.
For instance, it could
tax land, which was--
at the moment, parking
lots in the downtown
are used as investment
centers, waiting for the market
to reach a point where you could
capitalize on the land fully.
In Johannesburg,
you tax the value
of land at a higher rate
than only land itself.
You assume the
potential of building
as a function of the
cost of the land,
or the value of the land,
not the cost of the land.
And so the public
here intervenes
by making sure that land
doesn't lie fallow for too long.
So the public can speed up
development or slow it down.
Kevin Lynch, in
the Place Utopia,
talks about different
speeds of development.
This would be one of the tools.
An interesting thesis which
looked at urban agriculture
in Brooklyn argued
that urban agriculture
was one of the modalities of
land use which could easily--
which was very flexible.
It could either remain
agriculture and produce goods,
or it could give way to
more dense development
without having to
replace buildings.
I want to go on.
The last function that the
public has in this game
is education and marketing.
In Italian towns in
the early Renaissance,
towns produced books which are
called praise books, which set
out to advertise their town.
There's a nice
little book written
by an Italian woman
on these books,
and there's a parallel
literature in Islam
called the Fada'il books.
I think there are three
Fada'il books about Jerusalem,
which set out systematically
what the attractions are
of the city.
It's like "I Love New York"
or a version of making
the public possibility
that the city has
into a marketing device.
So the public has an
enormous number of powers.
And I'm assuming the society
is a market society, as I'm
assuming that most of the
propositions which I'm going
to be examining
will be propositions
in a democracy in which
power will be distributed
through systematically,
and people
will be able to take
part in various processes
to influence the way the
public and the market act.
We'll examine this in the
World Trade Center story.
We'll look at what the New York
Times, what role the New York
Times played, what
role CNN played.
But we'll get to
that in a minute.
I'm not going to talk about the
planning technology of decision
making.
It's arcane and
complicated and doesn't
deal with physical form.
It idealizes certain
techniques in decision making,
and thank you very much.
It's not of great
interest to me.
What we've come to realize--
and I think Kevin
Lynch put it well--
we have a city building
process which is complex
and plural, marked by conflict,
cross purposes, bargaining,
and whose outcome, while
often inequitable or wanted,
seems as uncontrollable
as a glacier.
He argues this
contentious argument,
a highly-decentralized
decision process
in which the immediate
uses of a place
make the decisions
about its form
is an accepted ideal,
both because it reinforces
the user's sense of
competence, and because it
is more likely to result in
a well-fitted environment.
This is probably
true of us from--
this probably true when the
scale of the proposition
is small and
diminishes in utility
as the proposition gets bigger.
Who would you ask
to make a decision,
to influence a decision on
whether Route 495 should
be widened?
Do you do a poll?
You can do a poll.
What utility, what would
you base your results on?
There are users who are
not capable of taking part
in the poll.
There are users
who are too young,
and are only going to be of
age once the proposition is
completed.
There are handicapped
people, and so on, and so on.
The utility of user
participation in general,
then, is spatially conditioned.
we have one street in
Cambridge which needs repair,
I think it would be a good
idea to talk to the people who
live on that street and ask them
what needs, what priorities,
what problems do they have?
Are there too many
dogs on the street?
Are there too many holes which
are not repaired on the street?
It makes an assumption
about the unique knowledge
that people have about their own
situation, which professionals
don't have, only have
to a limited extent.
And so buying into this unique
knowledge is an enormous asset.
I mentioned that in the New
Towns Committee in London
did a broadcast in
1946 asking people
what a good size
for a town would be.
That is the sort of nonsense
use of participation.
But active participation
on a small scale
has become almost
professionally mandated
in the change of
an American city.
Some people would argue that
it frustrates development.
I think development has
built itself into a position
to take account of it.
The fees for user participation
in the big-dig project
equal the fees for urban design.
So the shape of the road,
which is largely mandated
by engineering concerns,
you can't say it
should be painted red,
or green, or yellow,
the real crude rules, about
which you will understand,
about maintaining the perceptual
quality of automobiles
at 50 miles per hour.
But the right to
terminate, to exit
the expressway into
Watertown-- or, no,
it doesn't go into
Watertown-- into Chelsea
requires, probably, a
bargaining arrangement
whereby Chelsea is given a new
library by the federal funds
that come in to
pay for the project
in order to buy the
right for the road
to connect at that point.
So public participation,
which we'll
see a number of examples
of in the slides
I will show you,
probably as a summary,
is a fundamental
aspect of democracy.
It requires an educated--
not educated, but
transparent-- population.
People are educated
in different ways.
Formal education
doesn't necessarily
mean that you're sensitive
to your own environment.
You're probably so
overlaid by questions
as to how much your
property is worth,
and whether if a
Black person buys
a property on the same
street, your property is
going to be devalued.
These are important questions.
The major model
by which urbanism
is being transacted
and taught has
been that the great
improvements in cities
have come about when great,
powerful figures, super figures
are in control.
Robert Moses is a
great American example.
In over 40 years,
he built $28 billion
worth of projects,
the largest city
builder in America's history.
I handed out to you
a couple of things.
The first pages are some
notes I made from Ramparts
in March, 1975, when
Robert Caro's book on Moses
was just published.
Ramparts was a left-wing,
radical journal,
and it asked these six people,
those names on the left, what
they thought about, what they
thought the problem with Moses
was.
And I tried to list them in my
own handwriting, what I think.
One of the interesting
ones is the last one.
The second-last man,
Temco, says that Moses
didn't understand
architecture, therefore
he made bad decisions.
Berman follows up by
saying, Moses actually
did understand architecture.
Look at Sigfried Giedion's book
Space, Time, and Architecture.
The flyleaf has one of Moses's
elevated highway intersections
on its cover.
Gideon talks about the
similarities between Baroque
form and highway curvatures.
He talks about the
great Borromini building
in Rome, the two churches,
which is not [ITALIAN],,
the other one.
It's near the pantheon.
Forgive me, I can't remember.
My memory is gone.
Gideon makes a claim
that we should,
you can well understand
Moses's reaction to that claim,
that he was actually
doing things
which were being appreciated by
one of the great philosophers
of modern architecture.
But these are
tendentious comments.
Let's look at Moses's record.
The argument is
that a good city is
a city of grand design,
large public works.
It's important to have a large
figure who can superintend over
all the bureaucratic
complexities
and barriers of city form.
Moses, the masses are
incapable or unwilling to act.
If allowed to intervene,
no single product
could ever be delivered.
You cannot have the changes
you need in cities without
conflict, hurting some people.
Moses is quoted as saying
"you can't make an omelet
without breaking eggs."
But Moses moved over 100,000
people out of their houses
in East Tremont, in
the East Tremont.
500,000 people were displaced.
This was a neighborhood of
Blacks, Irish, and Jews.
He wished to build the
Cross Bronx Expressway.
He used a private company
to relocate people.
The company had four offices
far away from the neighborhood,
and never had regular hours.
When an available new
apartment was to be looked at,
there were four floors of
people already on the staircase.
Comparable price
was never achieved.
Demolition, even when people
didn't wish to move out,
demolition started, and
subsequent vandalism
was used to increase
the working, the moving
out, the speed by
which people moved out.
This is the sordid side
of the grand master.
Moses had charisma.
The book starts with him at Yale
as a brilliant student, ideal,
wanting to dedicate his
life to public service,
to helping the lower classes.
But he was strong.
He was a very good swimmer.
But he was a nasty man.
In the book, he doesn't help
his brother who needs help.
All of these things
paint a picture
of a flawed master,
a kind of a Beethoven
who, if you look too carefully,
doesn't ever wash his clothes.
One of the interesting
things about Moses
was not only the
scope of his work.
He built 600 miles of highway.
He built the Verrazzano Bridge.
He built a number of bridges.
He built a number of centers in
Manhattan, the United Nations,
the Colosseum, Lincoln Center,
all the products of his reign.
He was, for reasons which
I don't quite understand,
convinced that automobile
transportation was inexorably
the solution to
the American city.
For instance, the Long Island
Expressway cost $500 million,
or $500 billion. $500
million, I think, $500 million
at the time.
He could have added 4
feet for mass transit.
This would have cost 20% more.
He didn't.
Or he could have purchased
land and kept it in escrow
for further transit for
something like $20 million
more, but he didn't.
How did he achieve this
power in a democracy,
is perhaps one of the
more interesting things.
How do you achieve such power?
AUDIENCE: How do you
achieve such power
in a city that portrays itself
to be very sophisticated?
JULIAN BEINART: Well, it is
sophisticated in many respects.
There's some of the most
wonderful restaurants
in the world, and great
opera companies, and so on.
Now, I think the
interesting thing
that one learns from
looking at this case
carefully is that he
used the public authority
system to build power.
Moses was never elected
to office in the 40 years.
At his peak, he wasn't
challenged seriously
by any governor of
the New York State.
New York Times in its
private memorandum
claims that he could not be
criticized in the newspaper
without special documentation.
But he gained his power from
taking over and gaining power
in the public authority,
which possesses
not only the powers of
a large corporation,
but some of the powers
of a sovereign state.
It has the power
of eminent domain
that permits the seizure
of private property,
and the power to
establish and reinforce
rules and regulations.
The public authority has two
other vital characteristics.
It's controlled by a
board of directors,
which can be as
small as one member,
and they can issue bonds.
Haussmann understood this.
Haussmann used his understanding
of physical economics
in order to transform Paris.
In 1960, he was the sole member
of the Henry Hudson Parkway
Authority, one of three members
of the Triborough Bridge
and Tunnel Authority,
Commissioner of the New York
City Parks Department, City
Construction Coordinator,
a member of the City
Planning Commission,
Chairman of the Mayor's
Slum Clearance Committee,
Head of the City Office
of Civil Defense,
a member of the New
York City Youth Board,
President of Long Island State--
oh, god, it just goes on--
president of the Jones Beach
State Parkway Authority,
the Long Island
Parkway Authority,
chairman of the New York
State Tunnel Authority.
Having power in so
many domains, which
allows you to
reticulate decisions
which individual
entities can't assume.
If I'm on one board, and
I want a highway to move
through a park, I can use
the connected power system,
or the contiguous power system.
He also used, he
also had a great--
with power comes the
capacity in this country,
and probably anywhere in
the world, to assume wealth.
He got big gifts
from the Rockefellers
for the building of the
United Nations property,
and so on, and so on.
The question is, what kind of
city did he leave New York in,
and would we have been
worse off, had there
been no figure like Moses?
In our field, we should be
able to answer these questions.
But there's so many variables.
Nobody probably will
ever be able to assume
the power through the
public corporation system
as Moses did.
We have a completely different
set of environmental issues.
We have all kinds of different
public groups, issues of youth,
issues of gender,
issues of race,
all trends in the importance
of a super figure right now.
Look at what Mayor Bloomberg
is spending his time doing.
There's no Federal Highway
construction program.
So he's not building
any highways,
at lease none that I'm--
Manhattan, it's impossible
to move through Manhattan,
because they're
building subway--
renewing the gas system and
building the Second Avenue
Subway.
So when, in the
history of a town,
do you need somebody who
can assume total power?
Who'd be able to
answer this question?
In a democracy, you
do so when the society
is threatened absolutely.
Remember Foucault's
rules for what happened
when the plague occurred?
One of the problems of the
project of environmentalism
is that the actual symbols
of environmental degradation
are not impacting
people sufficiently,
not in this country,
not in New York.
And in a democracy,
people will tend
to be lazy about a great
deal of things which
they will suspend until some--
Hurricane Sandy hasn't probably
caused much of a change
in maintaining
flood control land,
and probably will
never result in
major infrastructural changes.
It means that the
only way that you're
going to be able to
get all of this done
is probably through waiting for
an emergency situation, when
the cost of repairing
the conditions
are 5,000 times higher.
It's a bleak prospect.
It's easy enough to criticize
Robert Moses and Jane Jacobs,
as legions of
liberals have done,
but it's worth speculating
about the state
of our business in a democracy.
What do you think?
Have you thought about
Robert Moses ever?
Well, what did you think of him?
You must have some thoughts.
You must know something
about the man.
You have the greatest
urban builder
in this country's history,
not a trivial figure.
Are we likely to have
people like that again?
AUDIENCE: Even if we put
more mechanisms and checks
and balances, the
reality is that there
are people have the
capability of achieving
a lot of power and influence
and just drive context.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And in
fact, oftentimes,
the population in different
places and different cultures
do like that, whether
if it's proper or not.
So there is a part
of the population
that actually is pleased
with the notion of somebody
taking charge.
JULIAN BEINART: Sure.
We are all lazy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We're all lazy.
JULIAN BEINART:
And to the extent
that I can trade off my
concerns about my health
to my doctor, who, if he's kind,
he behaves like a psychoanalyst
and relieves me of
worry, I will do nothing
about eating my pills at
the right time, because he--
I've found that
going to see a doctor
and saying that I train at
a health club twice a week
immediately makes me feel--
makes them feel good about me.
Anyway, that's a
bit of an aside.
The interesting thing
is not to, I think,
focus on these extremes,
to imagine cities
as building themselves
over a long period of time
and being much more engaged
in the proper process
by which things happen.
You know, Moses's
work is monumental.
So is Napoleon's for the
Champs-Élysées and Haussmann
for the Boulevard
de l'Opéra in Paris.
Over a period of time, another
generation has grown up.
Monuments, when we deal with
memory in monuments, one of--
I forget his name--
Robert Musil, the
French critic, says
monuments are amongst
the most forgettable
of items we produce.
You drive through France,
and you stop for coffee
in the afternoon
in a small town,
and you're sitting
in the square,
and you look at the monument
of a man on a bronze horse.
He fought in the
Battle of Algiers
in god alone knows when.
No small child in the town
pays any notion to him
except that there's
a monument there.
So it is often with cities.
We ingest the new very quickly.
We assign it to a
category of the past.
Certain aspects of the
past can create value
by being so much of the past.
AUDIENCE: How much
political process is there?
How much are they momentarily
lost in social memory?
And people forget about
the guy whose monument
was dedicated to, but
how much, in the end,
those monuments become fixtures
in the city and remain in time?
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
The one in the central square
in this little French city
that I'm talking about
will never again much
leverage in that
town or anywhere.
It's just a gift because
this man was born there,
and so on, and so on.
Let's delay talking about
memory seriously when
we, in a few weeks' time,
deal with Maurice Halbwachs'
book The Collective Memory and
the whole idea of monuments,
and temporary monuments, and
permanence, and temporariness,
and so on.
Let's just talk briefly
about the World Trade Center.
There are a number of actors
which started the game.
There's the
governor, Mr. Pataki,
who controls the lease, the
sea port authority they gave
to Mr. Silverstein, the
developer, whose towers were
destroyed by some
nasty airplanes.
There's the mayor of the city.
There are the victims' families.
See, if we put them
on a diagram together,
they all wish to interact in
the creation of something which,
both as utility, as real estate,
but has nourishment for loss.
It's a tough combination.
The mayor and the
governor get together
and form a Lower
Manhattan Development
Corporation which has-- and
it's another public corporation.
It seems to me that in New
York particularly, things
are so divided that public
corporations for almost
every single item
can be created,
and Moses took a lot
of advantage of that.
The first thing
this the LMDC does
is it hires a firm of
planners and architects
to make six different
models of the site
as what they call placeholders.
This is just to
describe to the world
what you can build on the site.
The response to this
is very negative.
People say, this is
completely classless.
It's unemotional.
It's got no guts.
It doesn't mean anything.
It's just a banal
disposition of space.
The LMDC, the New York
Times attacks this procedure
and publishes, you can see
in the piece I gave you,
a little extract from its
publication, "Don't Rebuild,
Reimagine."
It proposes a new high
road on the West side which
links down to Battery Park.
It gets Zaha Hadid
and Peter Eisenman
to design funny-shaped
housing on the road.
It has Rafael Vinoly doing
the new subway station.
The LMDC have got
to do something,
so they decide to do something
called an innovative design
study.
This is not a
design competition.
They're going to pay
selected architects
flat fee of $40,000 each.
The seven teams that take
place each paid about $500,000
out of their own pockets,
just to take part.
There were very few
limitations or rules
set up for the computation.
On December the 18th,
2002, the seven teams
were asked to make a public
presentation broadcast live
on television, as well as set
up an exhibition at the World
Financial Center Winter Garden.
The exhibit was up for a month
and drew 100,000 spectators.
CNN, the New York Post did polls
showing a strong preference
for Lord Foster, Libeskind,
and the Think Team's projects.
So much for public
participation.
I haven't got time to go
into the three projects.
Foster proposed two enormously
tall towers linked together.
They were called the Kissing
Towers project, really quite
a silly project, because when
you build so much square feet,
you need to build separately.
If you build two towers with
this massive square footage,
the chances of you selling
enough square footage
at a fast enough rate to
fill the whole building
would be very difficult.
So buildings are generally
targeted in size, and
this is 776 feet high.
Anyway, the Think Team's group
proposed a megastructure.
Their scheme was called
not the kissing towers,
but the cultural center.
It would be the tallest building
in the world, of course.
There would be a
great hall 30 stories
above the ground level covering
13 acres of open space.
A stainless steel system would
hold these towers up in place.
There was a certain
transparency.
They claimed that
the scheme resembled
the Eiffel Tower, which is
very difficult to understand.
Then there was Daniel Libeskind,
a Polish born Jew whose parents
died in the Holocaust.
He made his presentation
at the Winter Garden
by relating his vision
of the Statue of Liberty
when he immigrated to New York.
Norman Foster used a video of
a little girl in a red dress
as an important part
of his presentation.
All of this has
been written about.
There are books
about this story,
all about the kind of
commodification of the six
weeks after the Winter Garden.
Two were chosen,
Libeskind and Think.
The final committee
preferred the Think scheme.
The New York Times
And Rafael Vinoly,
the head of the team,
went to bed on
the Thursday night
assuming that him
project had won.
He got a phone call at
breakfast the next morning
to say that the governor had
preferred Libeskind's scheme,
and the governor had greater
power than the mayor,
and so Libeskind was chosen.
Before the catastrophe,
Silverstein, the real estate
developer, had already
hired SOM to build
a new building for him.
SOM coyly didn't take
part in the competition.
He emerged politically
as the great force,
David Childs of the
SOM produced what
he called the Freedom Tower.
They asked that Libeskind was
given 49% of the commission,
they pushed him out.
And we now have the 1,776-foot
high Freedom Tower as a result
of this complex
interrelationship between
the media.
The mourning relatives
got the result
of a competition of
a memorial space.
Calatrava was chosen to
do the train station,
and that's where it
stands at the moment.
What's it going to
matter in 25 years time?
Nobody will know this story.
We are only
rehearsing this story
to put you in a
position of being
critical of ways in which
it could be done better.
This is a completely
bungled, amateurish kind
of claptrap
operation, the problem
of choosing major monuments.
The Eiffel Tower occurred
through the genius
of an undistinguished
French structural engineer.
The Ferris wheel came from
an undistinguished betting
computation.
No, the Eiffel Tower wasn't
a competition, sorry.
The Ferris wheel for Chicago.
The Statue of Liberty
was a donation
by the French government
to America, not even
an American product.
And every baseball game
starts with the singing
of the National Anthem,
god alone knows why.
And the foreign-born
Statue of Liberty
is still the single evidence
of American democracy
in physical form.
Where does it
leave us theorists?
You work on the
stochastic opportunity
that competitions have,
that a young Asian immigrant
to the United
States will come up
with a brilliant solution to
the Vietnam War competition,
putting the names of all the
people who died on the facade
so that generations of children
will be able to recognize
their family name against
the simple embodiment
of a single monument.
Maybe that's what the
human species is all about,
all we can do.
I don't know.
I'm not empowered by the
story that I've just told you.
It seems to me to
have all kinds of--
I don't know if Robert
Moses would have done
better, had he been in power.
After all, perhaps the form
doesn't matter that much.
I keep on remembering
what Khrushchev said,
looking back on Stalin's attempt
to build the Lomonosov well,
not attempt-- he's building the
Lomonosov University decorated
to hell and looking
like a large cathedral
set of buildings, and so on,
filled with decorative systems.
Khrushchev said, if we'd
have built simple buildings,
we could have employed, we
could have housed 300,000 more
students.
Let's forget about all of
this monumental nonsense.
I'm asking questions which
are very difficult to answer.
I'm sorry.
That's not what I'm here for.
I'm supposed to
tell you what to do.
All I can point out is
that society doesn't
know what it wants to do.
And maybe in a democracy,
that's all that matters,
that you're always
alive to opportunities,
and you do the best you can.
And if you believe
in perfection,
stop being a member of society.
Become a hermit.
But the failures of democracy
are only tolerable if they
are temporary, I suppose.
The arguments about gun control
in this country are insane.
The evidence is
violently against it.
90% of the population wants
some background checks on guns.
At the same time, we're
going to probably move
towards national
legislation in favor
of same-sex marriages, which
25 years ago in this democracy
would have sounded insane.
So I'm arguing that there
may be some relief for us
in assuming that we
are only elements
in the democratic system.
And provided we maintain
the democratic system,
we can use our
imagination as best
we can to fulfill our
obligations of giving form
to societal needs.
I'm just going to mention
very briefly, because we've
got to look at
pictures, another way
of dealing in a
Democratic society
is redressing social imbalances.
That's what's
commonly known as--
what's the term now?
Anyway, it argues that
in a democratic society,
groups have equal access,
don't have equal access
to support systems.
So the case where this form
of planning really originally
starts in [? Lupo's ?]
book, very good book,
the story is very
well-explained.
The highway system
495, 128, a proposition
exists for building
an inner-belt highway
through Cambridge
to make linkages
of all kinds towards
the main roads,
expressways towards the west
and the south, and the north,
of course.
The question of where this inner
belt should run is at issue.
One of the candidates is the
rail line just running next
to MIT.
MIT objects.
It makes a foolish decision
to hire an Irish lawyer,
who in court, in the hearing
says that MIT cannot stand
having automobiles so close,
because it's got its sensitive
laboratories, the magnet
laboratory which is helping
our troops in Vietnam, when MIT
has claimed that it has nothing
to do with the
Vietnam War at all.
So MIT is embarrassed
publicly and loses.
One of our colleagues here,
Bob Goodman, on the faculty,
goes out and forms
a group, takes
a bunch of professionals with
him, and they form a group--
advocacy planning is the
term I was looking for--
advocating the
rights of the people
in Cambridge Port who don't
want the highway at all.
Finally, they win, and
there's no highway built,
and Cambridge is a
different city altogether
than what would have
been with a tunnel--
not a tunnel--
cutting the Earth,
running through either
next to MIT or--
so what has taken place?
A professional has given support
to a group who don't normally
have professional support in a
situation of public contention.
The other group deals with
the education of people.
There's a whole
variety of types.
There's political education, the
project of Giancarlo de Carlo
for steelworkers in Terni in
Southern-- not Southern Italy,
Middle Italy--
where he's asked to
design workers' housing.
He has these public
meetings and designs
certain types of housing.
When the people
complain that he's
giving them too much space,
he says, you're stupid.
You should argue for more space.
If you're wealthy,
all of you don't
have to get up at the same
time to use the bathroom.
You need two bathrooms
per family if you're poor.
He goes on and on, and
the people take this up.
He designs this situation
and gets away with it.
There's information giving,
telling people about the city.
A good city is one in which
people are well-informed.
Patrick Geddes' Outlook Tower,
the IBA in Berlin, Media City,
city of benign consumerism,
Signs and Lights project,
Yellow Pages, opening
up the city's resources.
The visible city is the idea
the city is a schoolroom.
Let's look at some of these.
This is a project in Terni.
I'm just going to run
through these early ones.
The project in Terni, the
housing which was built.
You can argue against the use
of concrete in this form, fixed,
when an environment of
greater flexibility.
These are some other
examples of small town.
This is in York, Pennsylvania,
the redevelopment of,
the renewal of a
rundown town square,
people being shown drawings and
asked to learn about the place
and give their opinion next.
Bologna, Red Bologna,
suburban housing
and the redevelopment of parts
of the center of the city.
Next.
The redevelopment
proposals forced by people
argue for maintaining the
facade, existing facade
of the buildings, the
housing, but putting it
into a new typology of
larger space behind.
So you get this idea of
almost the exact counterpart
of this original street,
but in depth increased.
Next.
Pittsburgh, an attempt to build
a model of the neighborhood
that's going to be
renewed in an attempt
to actually have
people participate
spatially and
physically in the space.
Next.
This is an Italian hill
town in the Abruzzo.
This is an architect, Belgian
architect by the name of Kroll,
building for Leuven University,
in which he imitates
the individual anarchy of
each builder of the house
in the left in an
attempt to choose
a system of formal
randomness to give
his facade a particular quality.
This is a student dormitory
like any student dormitory
in the world.
That's a town that's built
up by a process of adjustment
and change over time.
Next.
Robert Moses and
three presidents.
Major figures are always large,
and they're always photographed
to make them seem larger.
I wonder who's a small dictator.
Next.
These are from Caro's book.
This is a proposition showing a
dotted line for the Long Island
Expressway.
And the actual
route that's chosen
is contoured by it missing all
of the property, almost all
of the property in large
holdings by wealthy people.
Next.
I haven't got time
to go into detail.
That's Moses's proposal
to build a bridge,
and his depiction of the bridge
in public in the upper two
diagrams, where the
lower diagram, in fact,
shows its impact on the
city more dramatically.
Next.
This is an MIT--
we're talking about
education now--
this isn't an MIT project
called Signs and Lights which
says one of the
things we can do is
create much more intelligence
in the built formal environment.
The project on the right argues
for the coloring of the road
surface to provide,
to indicate that you
can travel at different speeds.
Next.
A project in Genoa, in Italy,
in which a neighborhood is
cleared, and only the fossils,
the essential elements
of the neighborhood
are maintained,
giving the people an
understanding of what
they've got to work with.
On the basis of
their understanding,
they precipitate
reactions, create changes,
produce changes, which
are on the right.
Next.
Cedric Price's work in England,
the idea of building places
where people can--
this is prior to social media.
This is actually making
places in the city--
the one on the right is
called the Fun Palace,
and the one on the left is
called the Interaction Center--
where people randomly
could meet each other
and partake of joyous activity.
Next.
This is a Bedford Stuyvesant New
York project, a Ford Foundation
study, which is interesting.
The project is to insert
a new community college
in a very poor area, and
instead of building a new campus
with glass buildings,
the form of the building,
the inserted buildings, are
within the existing framework
of the town.
All the facilities that are
built for the community college
are shared by the community.
In fact, the curriculum
for the community college
is set by the needs
of the community.
The sports facilities up
on the top on the left
are all partly
for the community,
partly for the students.
Next.
The park in Philadelphia
on the left.
The city, the school
without walls.
The city has got enough
input, education input in it
to serve as a school.
Next.
Metro Education
Project in Montreal,
which argues that you
can stop building schools
and utilize meetings and
connections with people
in the city itself.
For instance, up
there is a meeting
with a professor who
is a big businessman.
And so the subway
system becomes a method
of utilizing all of the
available space which
can serve dual mode uses.
Next.
Oh, well, you can leave MIT.
The extraordinary
thing is that this
was 20 years ago, probably.
I'm trying to read what
it says at the top.
To leave the white walls gray or
paint them white is vandalism.
Your environment is changing.
Get yourself, get
together with it.
No one knows better how
to create your environment
than you do.
Does your environment
respond to your needs?
What a statement of
anarchy invitation.
This is one of the posters which
I photographed at the time.
Next.
"Up against the Wall Street
Journal," an urban imperialist.
This is a time when
the form of the city
was politically significant
to the students in the two
universities.
Next.
Herrey was MIT's
real estate boss.
Next.
The university's response,
the University and the City,
Harvard's University
and the City.
These are all University reports
saying how great things are.
Next.
There's a thesis done
by Monika Unger called
"The Politics of Urbanity" on
the history of the attempts
in Brussels, after
the Manhattan plan,
to respond vigorously
to the plan.
The plan was to internationalize
Brussels, with tall buildings,
as the center of
the European market.
And here are posters
emanating from the society
itself saying no to Carrere, no
to Venturi, no to Chernikhov,
no to Kroll.
Next.
Posters which set out the way
in which local neighborhoods
should be fixed.
A whole set of items like
this monthly magazine
for the urban
struggles, information
about the development
projects at Brussels,
the work of
inhabitants' committees,
theaters, schools
of architecture,
cinema, arts museums,
all being formed together
to form a protest environment
with educational material
in the form of daily
posters on the left.
Next.
So all of this
stuff is an attempt
to influence the
form of the city,
often stopping negative
things from happening.